the movie opens up late at night when
Cameron and Janice hucker a married
couple with an unfortunate last name go
to a dark Forest to hide a dead body
Janice is scared and holds her prayer
beads tightly feeling guilty about what
they've done but her cruel husband
Cameron tries to comfort her saying it
was an accident and they didn't mean to
hurt anyone after burying the body they
quickly leave the area before the
sunrise the scene then fast forwards to
a year later where a beautiful girl
Colleen Stan is attempting to hitchhike
a ride to Westwood California after a
while a couple Drives By the same road
they happen to be none other than
Cameron and Janice Colleen requests a
ride and they happily accept during the
journey the couple asks Colleen some
questions and finds out that she wants
to surprise her best friend in Westwood
moreover no one knows that she is going
there for some reason this Delights
Cameron and he stops by a gas station to
take a break when Colleen goes to use
the restroom Cameron creepily takes out
a wooden box from the trunk and puts it
in the back seat of the car Colleen
returns shortly after and notices the
box but she doesn't think much of it
they then continue driving and Cameron
suggests visiting the Ice Caves before
going to Westwood Colleen is a bit
skeptical about the idea that she wants
to reach California before it gets dark
but having no other options left she
agrees following this they stopped the
car in a lonely Place Janice leads the
way to the caves but Colleen starts to
sense that something is not right
suddenly Cameron pulls out a knife and
holds it against her neck he then
blindfolds her handcuffs her hands and
pushes her back into the car that's not
all he even places her head inside the
wooden box so that she can't see where
they're taking her in the next scene the
couple brings Colleen to their house in
Red Bluff once there Cameron undresses
the poor girl and ties her up he then
brutally whips her while Janus watches
in horror Cameron gets excited by the
violence and the screams indicating that
he is a psychopath after he is done for
the day Cameron Shane's calling to a
table and puts her head back inside the
Box leaving her trapped and terrified
early the next morning Janice anxiously
approaches her husband seeking Clarity
on their plans for Colleen Cameron
replies that they'll dispose of her when
he grows tired of her he then heads to
work leaving Janice alone with her
doubts and worries during the day the
sound of Colleen's tearful cries
interrupts Janice's moments of Peace so
she goes downstairs to confront the
situation Colleen pleads desperately
promising not to tell anything to the
police if they release her however
despite her pleas Janus shows No Remorse
and simply walks away later at night
Cameron returns home attending to
Colleen's basic needs while
simultaneously beating and assaulting
her Janus unable to Bear the anguished
screams wears headphones with loud
volume she's probably listening to
Imagine Dragons after he is done with
his cruel Antics Cameron gets tired and
goes to bed but before he can fall
asleep Janice approaches him with her
concerns she worries that keeping
Colleen with them is not such a good
idea she's like a ticking Time Bomb who
may explode at any time however Cameron
completely rebuffs Janice's claims and
instead reminds her of the vows she took
with him during marriage he also tells
her that he will not get intimate with
Colleen he only wants to use her as a
slave to fulfill his needs and desires
later at midnight Cameron constructs a
coffin-like box and cruelly locks
calling inside he also connects an
oxygen pipe to the coffin allowing the
victim to breathe and remain alive
imprisoned within the claustrophobic box
Colleen's mind wanders into a realm of
hallucinations Longing For Freedom
regrets flutter thoughts as she recalls
her father's advice to take the bus a
choice that she instantly refused
meanwhile Colleen's parents finally
learned that she has disappeared when
her landlord reveals that she hasn't
paid her rent alarmed they quickly head
over to the police desperate for answers
the scene then fast forwards by six
months and we get to know that Colleen
is still under the couple's abduction
one day Janice visits Cameron at his
workplace and reveals that she is
pregnant she also suggests releasing
Colleen as the scene around them could
disturb their child however Cameron
instantly resists the idea saying it is
too dangerous next Cameron devises a
Sinister plan to instill fear and
calling and prevent her from escaping he
manipulates her by claiming to work for
a company involved in the slave trade
Cameron cruelly asserts that Colleen is
his slave and warns her that if she
attempts to flee the company will
capture her and subject her to severe
consequences to intensify the fear he
fabricates stories of the company's
merciless treatment even threatening
harm to her family if she dares to
escape when the poor girl starts getting
worried Cameron makes her sign fake
documents promising her safety and
protection from the slave trading
company Janus who's desperate to have a
baby also goes along with the lies she
doesn't argue when Cameron claims that
she used to be a slave too but he
married her out of pity the following
day Cameron prepares Colleen by dressing
her and placing a collar around her neck
he renames her K and establishes that
she must regard him and Janice as her
Masters following their every command he
then instead directs Colleen that
whenever he calls out attention she must
quickly go to a designated spot remove
her gown and raise her hands as expected
the scared girl agrees without any
questions later while carrying out her
cleaning duties Colleen comes across a
Bible and tries to read it but just then
Janice arrives and snatches it from her
she then reminds Colleen of her
worthlessness and asserts that her sole
purpose is to endure suffering a few
months later still when the landlord
asks Cameron if he can check the furnace
the latter gets scared and tells his
wife they need to move to a new place
not long after Janice gives birth to a
baby girl little baby psycho hooker and
only Cameron assists her during labor
after a while Colleen is let out briefly
so that she can meet the child whom they
have named Amber although Colleen is
sent back right away she is delighted to
have witnessed the baby girl a year
later the evil couple moves to a new
place far from the city one evening
during dinner Janice learns that Colleen
didn't set a fork for her enraged she
calls the girl Lazy and a liar who is
good for nothing Cameron also gets mad
punishes her brutally but after a while
Janice learns that the fork had
accidentally fallen on the floor making
her feel guilty the next morning Cameron
scares Colleen with a story about a
slave who was eliminated for trying to
escape he reminds her how lucky she is
that he's her master it seems like he's
preparing to take her outside a few days
later Cameron removes Colleen's collar
and dresses her in regular clothes he
then takes her out to gather firewood in
the mountains making her happy this is
the first time she has left the house in
years Colleen asks if she can go home
one day but Cameron says it's unlikely
later while collecting firewood Cameron
accidentally hurts himself with an ax
and falls to the ground at this moment
Colleen gets the perfect opportunity to
flee but she hesitates and stays to help
him when they return home she tends to
his injury but Janus becomes jealous and
insists on taking care of it herself as
the couple prepares for bed Janice tries
to engage in coitus but Cameron rejects
her advances feeling unloved she bursts
out in anger saying he has started
liking this slave more than her she then
storms out of the room but not before
commanding Cameron to return Colleen to
the box and never touch her again three
years pass and Colleen remains captive
under Cameron and Janice's control on
one occasion Janice briefly releases her
from the box to empty her urinal and
Colleen catches a glimpse of Amber now a
grown girl the sight leaves her
wondering how many years have passed
since her abduction one day the family
decides to go to Lake Tahoe leaving
Colleen can find in her box
unfortunately when they are away a
malfunction in the ventilation system
causes Colleen to suffocate leading her
to experience Vivid hallucinations
suddenly she awakens and desperately
kicks the Box Until It Breaks open later
the family returns from their trip to
the lake Cameron goes to check on
Colleen but shockingly discovers that
she is missing he frantically searches
the house hoping she is still there and
to his relief Colleen is hiding behind
the shower clutching a Bible as he gets
ready to punish her she honestly tells
him about the broken ventilation the
scene then fast forwards five years and
now Colleen has become a part of the
family one day Janice and Colleen attend
church together however the priest's
sermon hits too close to home for Janus
triggering painful memories of her past
mistakes overwhelmed with guilt she
trembles with unease but Colleen reaches
out and holds her hand offering Solace
and support as time passes Janice finds
it increasingly difficult to endure her
husband's abusive Behavior she also
develops a growing sympathy for Colleen
and becomes concerned about Amber's
future after another year Cameron
delivers exciting news to Colleen the
company has granted her permission to
visit her home this Revelation fills her
with joy but Cameron emphasizes that she
must undergo obedience training before
she can meet her family shortly after he
takes her outside and hands her a
shotgun he then instructs her to point
the barrel at her own mouth and pull the
trigger the poor girl with tears in her
eyes obeys without protesting
fortunately the gun doesn't discharge
Arch and Colleen survives the harrowing
ordeal the next morning Cameron drives
Colleen to her parents house during the
journey he mentions the considerable
expenses he incurred to make all of this
happen prompting Colleen to express her
gratitude they then reached their
destination but before Colleen can
reunite with her family Cameron reminds
her of the constant monitoring by the
company urging her to be cautious and
avoid any mistakes after he leaves
Colleen lies to her family that he is
her boyfriend and that they have been
staying together for six years while
their parents are happy to see her after
so long her sister Bonnie senses that
something is amiss Bonnie wants to talk
about it but their father doesn't want
to spoil the moment at night she can't
resist asking Colleen why she hasn't
kept in touch for so long however the
scared girl avoids the topic the
following morning Bonnie begs calling to
tell her what's bothering her this time
the latter seriously considers spilling
out the truth but before she can open
her mouth Cameron comes to pick her up
as Colleen packs her things nervously
Cameron talks to her parents he tells
them that he and Colleen are planning to
get married soon after a while is the
two are about to leave Bonnie inquires
where they live now Cameron confidently
says that they're in California but
Colleen had told Bonnie they lived in
Oregon this confirms her suspicion that
something is wrong however she doesn't
say anything at the moment in the next
scene Cameron arrives home with Colleen
and tells her something shocking he
reveals that he actually is thinking of
marrying her and starting a family
unbeknownst to them Janice overhears
everything from nearby the next morning
Colleen sees Janice packing and asks
where she's going at first Jenna says
she's visiting her parents but later
says that she wants to end her marriage
with Cameron as she tries to leave
Cameron catches her and insists that she
has to return to the house however
Janice has reached her breaking point
and defiantly leaves with her father and
Amber Cameron is left distraught and
when Colleen tries to console him he
gets angry and reminds her that she's
still his slave he shouts the word
attention prompting her to quickly
undress and stand in the corner later
Cameron forcefully drags her into the
basement of his Shack and lock there
before closing the door he tells Colleen
that someone else will join her soon he
then gets into his car and drives away
leaving her shivering in the cold rain
elsewhere we see Janice at a church
begging God for forgiveness this is when
it Dawns on her that she has to help
Colleen before it's too late so without
wasting any time she heads home opens
the door to the basement and sets
Colleen free she then helps the poor
girl get dressed and tells her to leave
Colleen tries to argue that Cameron will
calm down and forgive her but Janus
reveals a shocking secret she mentions
that she and Cameron had imprisoned
another girl named marlitz a year
earlier at first Cameron pretended it
was a game but marlette's constant
screaming drove him so crazy that he
murdered her Janice also reveals that
they buried her body together in this
horrible event has deeply affected her
sometime later Cameron returns home with
a shovel planning to go to the shack but
to his horror Colleen is nowhere to be
seen on the other hand Janice is taking
Colleen to the bus stop asking her to go
home and live life freely when the boss
finally arrives Colleen hesitates
because she is still afraid of being
caught by the slave trade company
however Janice bluntly reveals that the
story about the company is a lie and
Cameron was never involved in it after
understanding the truth Colleen feels a
sense of relief she then gets out of the
car and enters the boss as she travels
back home Cameron can be seen devastated
crying on the floor as he has lost both
Janus and Colleen in the last scene we
get to learn that Janice confessed
everything to the police to cleanse her
guilt the police conducted an
investigation and as a result Cameron
was sentenced to 104 years in prison
Janice on the other hand was granted
immunity for testifying against him
unfortunately marlets's body was never
discovered the movie ends with the
police disclosing that Colleen was held
captive for 2
640 days which is equal to seven years
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching